Yeah,
I think they're all a number of
different examples in,
uh,
in different places.
I think it's hard to make sort of this
and I want to make any sort of sort of a
grand statement to say,
oh,
this executive gets it across the board.
I think there are,
you know,
you can,
you can point to what the New York Times
is done with,
uh,
with our apis instead of making that
information widely available at the
Guardian has done some similar things in
the UK.
Sticking in the UK.
You can,
you can look at the Telegraph which has
done.
They've really begun to sort of figure
out what,
what are the core functions that we need
to do and we need to own in house and
what are the ones that we can outsource.
Um,
whether it's sort of technology,
um,
or even forms of sort of the content
instead of,
and,
and the,
and the printing of the papers.
Um,
uh,
you can look at the Journal and what
they've had.
Some of the experiments that they've
done around around paid content and
trying to sort of find out how these,
both paid content and free content can
coexist on the web,
how to sort of have their cake and eat
it too,
with,
with traffic coming in,
but also having a,
having a subscriber base.
Um,
I mean,
I think there's a,
you know,
the fte sticking with the paid content
side of things where they sort of did
this metered model for content.
I think there's,
there's been a number of different
innovations and I think it ranges across
the board.
Um,
La Times.
Another great example of using
technology that's not their own to tell
stories better online,
uh,
in this case you,
the way that they use google maps.
I mean,
I,
I kind of always point them out as,
as,
as a perfect use case of this where,
um,
la times coverage of the wildfires,
which unfortunately is basically every
year you've got these series of
wildfires.
Uh,
and they just,
they,
they take Google maps to take our API.
They plug it in,
they put their images on there,
they put the stories,
they,
they annotate the map to show where the
damages were,
the evacuation areas are the latest
developments of it cause it's a very
visual story beyond just the,
the images of the fire itself,
but to see the location of it as well.
I'm just a really good example of how
they can use technology that's not their
own to tell stories in a different way.
That's just simply not even possible
offline.
If you take a look at the paper and you
can say,
well here's,
here's the fire,
but it's real time.
It's dynamic.
So I think there are,
there are a number of different people
who are doing interesting things and
those are just the big players that,
that doesn't even touch on all the sort
of small startups that are just doing a
really,
really interesting things.
Some which are just weird and strange
and ultimately maybe you'd say are bad,
um,
but are just,
are really encouraging attempts to sort
of try and figure out how to use the
medium differently.
I think.
Absolutely.
I mean,
I think that they have,
they are very aware of the traffic that
they get that is now beyond their
borders.
And that gets back into there.
There's the downside to the local
monopoly,
uh,
the local newspaper that had a monopoly
on information that all of a sudden it
sort of broken down.
But that's,
that's the downside from a business
model standpoint.
But the upside for the business model is
this,
that I,
I don't,
it doesn't cost a,
you know,
even a fraction of a penny to reach a
user who's,
you know,
tens of thousands of miles away from me
if I've got this great content.
So you see things like the Guardian,
the Telegraph,
the BBC,
which is,
you know,
really I would argue is,
um,
is,
is not just a,
a,
a UK source of news is really sort of a
global source of news done in some ways.
It always has been.
But,
um,
the way that they can reach people on
online is I think is,
is very different.
And they begin to think about how can I
cover stories differently?
Who's,
who's my audience?
I think that the definition of audience
is is rapidly changing.
The Guardian experimented a little bit
with having a,
a,
a bureau in the US and trying to set a
target information specifically for
those of us users,
but it's,
it's really trying to get those
different perspectives and being able to
read them.
Just clicking.
I mean like you don't have to go down to
the sort of know that the,
you know,
that one new stand that has all the
different international magazines and
newspapers.
I'm sort of maybe sort of frequented by
ex pats.
All that information is online and I
think that's really changed their ideas
of what their audiences and how to reach
people.